les gens ont commencé à faire la queue il y a cinq jours
à cause de toi, nous sommes numéro un dans 37
pays,
nous ne nous attendions pas à ce que tout cela se produise,
je ne sais pas si vous pourriez avoir un
changement de vie plus dramatique, un grand fan, je me
demande juste où  nous sommes notre truc à propos
des problèmes, c'est le manque de maison avec la
famille disparue mais nous sommes devenus littéralement comme
des frères maintenant parce que ma femme est depuis si longtemps et si
nulle part au monde tu ne pleures,
maman, eh bien, raccroche, alors avant que je
commence à pleurer et je comment  grand et célèbre
tu deviens tu seras toujours mon bébé il y a
trois ou quatre ans ce que nous faisions à
l'époque et maintenant nous cinq faisons une tournée mondiale
dans les plus grandes arènes
choisissons un autre clip
il y a un groupe nous sommes plus forts alors s'il
y a  j'étais cinq personnes seules j'ai
toujours voulu mon petit frère maintenant j'en ai
quatre n'essaye pas ça à la maison
je n'ai pas besoin de le boire maintenant résultat fais-le
je vis on est là